[Applause]
welcoming Tony to the Hall of Fame it's
a pair of Spurs who celebrated four
championships with him Tim Duncan and
Manu Ginobili Tony Parker
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry I have a lot of French people in
town sorry
[Applause]
yeah
wow
thanks to the Hall of Fame quarter class
2023.
uh unbelievable I have a lot of
connection with that class uh Paul Gasol
my teammate with the Spurs huge rivalry
Spain France Dirk Nowitzki with Dirk
Dirk
I went to New Jersey retirement your
great friend and a Texas rivalry was
fierce
D Wade
will play twice in the NBA finals
and people don't know that but he's my
little brother favorite player
so every time he will come to the house
and be like Dwayne way like all the time
and then be like man can you stop it
you're my own brother
but we won one so we're good we're good
very good
Becky Hammond
people don't know that but uh she's like
my big sister who have a great
relationship thanks for all your advice
to the years and I'm so happy to go to
the hall with you it's crazy
coach pop
I was told I was told
I was told that it was the first time
that a player and a coach going at the
same time to the Hall of Fame so that's
pretty cool
for the rest uh yes I can get rid of him
it's crazy
for the rest of the inductees it's an
honor to go with you guys in the Hall of
Fame thank you
so uh
my presenters
Tim Duncan
um
I started uh I started writing my speech
last week and I was trying to think like
why Tim is so special why to me so
special like it was like I couldn't
sleep you know why Tim is so special and
at the same time it's easy and the same
time it's hard so I will start with the
obvious to me is the best power forward
ever
[Applause]
that's the obvious but me wanna know he
has a special power super power with his
eyes
I'm gonna explain
he never
talked to get the ball never he'll just
look at me
and when you're 19 years old coming from
France it's very scary when Tim Duncan
looks at you
I play with a lot of teammates who will
complain to get the ball you know Bruce
Bowman like oh Tony I'm open Tony I was
open in the corner you know I'm like but
hey what's up Bruce
but uh but Timmy will just look at me
and I'll go to pop I'm like pop you give
me the look
and then probably like he really look at
you I was like yeah if you want a point
guard tomorrow we need to call to play
for him right now
and so that's why to me to me especially
and he's one of my presenters
[Applause]
Manu
is unique Manu is unique he's the most
unique player I ever play with and he
was so unique that pop didn't even know
what to do with him these first two
years
it was very Priceless as a point guard
to see Pop's faces after some of his
passes because when Manu you have two
passes you have the legend one that
everybody will talk about it was
unbelievable and the one that go to the
fans to the stands you know I mean Pop's
favorites there was a lot of those in
the first two years so we had a rough
start you know with Manu and a rough
beginning you know with Argentina too
you know the the actually the Argentina
media
um they thought like I didn't like Manu
I don't pass the ball enough to mano but
I never really understand that because
pop is the coach it's not my fault if
pop calls all the plays for Timmy and
Timmy will take all the shots I'm just
the point guard
[Applause]
so I need an ally and Manu was my Ally
at the beginning
so everybody knows that but I'm going to
say it again my rookie year
Timmy didn't talk to me my rookie year
and people think I'm crazy when I say
that but it's true to me don't like
French people
it doesn't like my French accent
is it not until I play against Gary
Payton who's one of my favorite point
guard where's Gary Payton where's
Garrett Gary love you
it's not until I play good in my rookie
against Gary Payton finally say one word
actually two words three words I
remember basically we'll be all right
so
we all good now
the little Frenchie
a little guy from Argentina and a
swimmer from the islands who knew we won
four championships together and it was
an honor to play with you guys
[Applause]
so my majority started with a big dream
I wanted to dream big and I wanted to go
in the MBA and I wanted to become the
first European point guard to make in an
MBA and I always tell my kids dream big
and when you say your dream to somebody
and he's not laughing at you you don't
dream big enough and so when I was in
France they would always say oh you're
too small you're too skinny you will
never make it but I'm the one who's
laughing now
[Applause]
my dad is from Chicago my mom is from
the Netherlands Amsterdam I'm born in
Belgium but I'm French so go figure
I grew up with the both cultures I felt
like I had the best of both worlds and
it helped me a lot for my journey to my
dad
um
[Applause]
I love you man
foreign
[Applause]
she was a health doctor helped me a lot
for the longevity of my career
I love you very much thanks for
everything to my two brothers TJ and
Pierre
[Applause]
those guys will do anything for me I
love you guys
[Music]
to Josh and Liam my two kids
I love the way you are you have great
Hearts I can't wait to see what you're
going to do in life and I know it's
going to be great
I love you very much
[Applause]
yeah they love the camera just like
Steve Nash kids remember Steve
I watch your your speech you know to
work on mine yeah they're the same
foreign
thanks for the support I love the way I
love the way you take care of me and and
my kids and you have a pure heart and
you make me want to be a better person
every day love you very much
I'm going to say some uh some quick
thanks uh to my French Mafia my friends
my team thanks for all the support
gaito 30 years of friendship
thanks man you like my brother Ms my big
sis thanks for always listening to me
and being there for me TT I didn't have
a big brother
but you were definitely my big brother I
will always remember when I torn my
ligament and they were saying that my
career was done and you flew 48 hours
after and you were helping me going to
the restroom and everything with my leg
I couldn't do anything you were always
there for me thank you very much
Natalie
it's very hard to find the words but the
only thing I know is I'm very lucky to
have you in my life got killer I don't
know where you're at you you got to be
the one who traveled the most to see me
play I will always remember 2005 NBA
Finals game seven your wife was pregnant
eight months and you still came that was
really that was risky
Sophia Ellen thanks for making my life
easier every day
Alexia Edwin Matilda Bros lil Sis love
you guys Matt Tina my boat Partners
can't wait to make more memories
together
Luciano Christina Agustin love you guys
to my team Stephen Newman you're the
best DJ Doma I have no words thanks for
everything you mean a lot to me Bill
Braden 18 years I don't know where
you're at love you too Neil Stefan over
my Infinity nine group all my Norfolk
partners team Rob Sean Danny thank you
very much I appreciate everything you do
for me and my family
uh the Spurs man
what uh what organization uh it starts
with RC Buford RC
[Applause]
RC you find me you find me and Thanks
for believing in me thanks for
convincing pop to do a second workout I
was definitely terrible on my first one
thanks for convincing him and I will not
be here without you thank you RC I love
you and I'll put Sam Preston on the same
group with you because Sam was there too
with you thank you
[Applause]
chip England chip England you might be
the only guy you watch all my shots my
whole career and it was very scary to me
when you decided to try to change my
shot to be consistent and my first year
working with you I made the All-Star
team so thanks for everything
obviously I had a lot of great teammates
uh David Robinson was David David
Robinson you were the original
you and George Gervin
Patty Mills George Hill Steve Smith I
can say a lot of my teammate Bruce Bowen
you are a hero growing up in France we
were watching you with my brothers you
always took care of me and you always
had my back Michael Finley I forgot to
mention you on my jersey retirement
forgot and I told you I'm not going to
forget in my hall of fame it's okay
you're on the Maverick side but remember
you won with us you won with the Spurs
you know
I will tell a quick story on Michael
Finn is one of my favorite teammates uh
in 2006 he decided to come to the Spurs
to win a championship because that's
what you do when you come to the Spurs
you want to win a championship and uh
and in 2006 we lost against the
Mavericks
so
Dirk had a hell of a play and we lost
and I remember I will always remember we
were in the locker room and you were
crying and I took that to heart like
like like you were crying and I was like
man we didn't we didn't do it and so
2007 my only motivation the whole year
it was to try to bring you a
championship and uh I remember when we
beat Cleveland sorry LeBron when we
would be Cleveland uh it was priceless
to see your face and that we got you a
championship
[Applause]
it starts with him Coach pop you're
unbelievable you're unbelievable I can
say okay I can say a lot of stuff about
you papa and the way you cursed on me
and the language that you used to to to
push me but
I have my kids here so I'm just gonna
keep it simple
at the end of the day you threw me on
the fire at 19 years old you in five
games into my rookie year you put me in
the back in the plane you call me and
you was like you're starting tomorrow I
was like really I was like did you talk
to Timmy
yeah because I was still thinking eating
like French people so I was like a
little bit scared you know
and perhaps that you'll be fine you
starting and the rest is history you're
always being the second dad to me pop
everything you did for me and my family
I appreciate everything thank you Papa I
love you
to the French team the French national
team uh we celebrated
um
two weeks ago we celebrated our 10-year
anniversary of our first gold medal the
only gold medal we won with the French
team and it was a great feeling I always
thought that if I didn't win with the
French national team that my career was
not going to be successful I was
obsessed with winning a gold medal so
it's true sometime I wish that Paul
Gasol was not born because I I would
have went a lot more gold medals but
sooner but because of you you pushed me
every year to come back with the
national team so I had some great
teammates Rudy gobert Nicola Batum Yan
mahimi but my two partner in crimes
Boris Dia and Ronnie choria you made it
work for it you made it work for it
every summer you made it worth it
to the Hornets I want to thank Michael
Jordan he was my idol growing up he's
the reason why I wanted to play
basketball he was my inspiration I had
post turbo in my whole room and uh you
know people always say never meet your
Idol but for me it was the opposite it
was unbelievable that now I had a great
relationship with him and I can call him
a friend so thanks for Michael and
thanks for the Hornets organization
[Applause]
to finish I feel very blessed it was an
unbelievable journey I never thought
somebody like me can experience
something like that so for all the kids
who are watching keep dreaming big thank
you very much I appreciate and love you
all let's have a good night
thank you